odda Fairport has seen more than its
fair share of difficulties over the past
decade losing major carriers years after
years of losses and a controversial
Welsh government takeover in 2013 to
name but a few
however the arrival of a Qatar Airways
flight from Doha means the airport has
pulled off a real coup beating regional
rivals like Bristol to deliver the first
link to the Gulf that opens up long-haul
connections to the rest of the world
well owner I spoke to the airport's
chief executive Deb barber I began by
asking how important this was to Cardiff
their way to describe it is
transformational it's the first time
that Wales and the West of England will
be connected directly into the Middle
East network and you know in terms of
connectivity it now just opens up this
region of the UK to the rest of the
world through Doha and I think you know
most importantly it's not just about
people travelling outbound but you know
it's going to be a huge stimulus forum
an investment for tourism so say it will
have a massive impact Freight and
exporting as well I know there you said
not just Wales but the West of England
you're competing squarely here with the
likes of Bristol Airport and Exeter
Airport in this instance well prior to
this route being launched in Cardiff
yesterday for people from our region to
go out to the Middle East it involved
are either trip up to London or
Birmingham the southwestern of England
and Wales haven't been served directly
so what this gives us now is an
opportunity to connect over 6.4 million
people in this part of the UK to that
network Qatar Airways already flies into
a four UK airports how did you convince
them to add a fifth to that how did you
sell Cardiff to them yeah a mistake it
has taken a long time basically we've
had confidence in our market and we knew
from all the data analysis that we've
been doing over the years that there is
absolutely a demand for this this
network in in our part of the country
we've got over 1.4 million people a year
are currently travelling at the m4 to
London from the South Western Wales two
routes on the cattle network so as I say
there there
awful lot of people who will now benefit
from this service and you know we we are
detailed discussions and involve lots of
journeys of our people out to Doha and
you know we've been able to say Qatar
Airways they are a you know a huge
airline huge business they are convinced
by rich data and that's what we were
able to give them British Airways don't
fly in or out of Cardiff although they
do have a big maintenance center at the
airport yes
cutter a big shareholder in bas parent
company do you think this might persuade
ba to start flying into battle Cardiff
again well I think you know we've been
all about building confidence in our
business we like to talk about
contagious confidence and the fact that
you know quatre Airways have got faith
in our market in our business we fully
anticipate will will stimulate growth
accorded both in terms of passengers and
freight activity so you know we're
really keen to sort of grow the business
generally so I mean have you actually
held conversations with British Airways
recently I'd say we we talked to we we
already have other IAG airlines
operating into and out of Cardiff and
dwelling for instance is a very
important customer for us Aziz Iberia
Express so we have great connectivity
with IAG and of course you know we we're
always talking to them about other
opportunities and in fact Willie Walsh
Berg recently about level and
opportunities for that airline in the
regions and Cardiff was one of the
airports that he mentioned linked to the
APD argument but you know Cardiff is
absolutely there on the radar now of the
big airlines and we're really keen to
see you know our business develop in you
know in line with what Qatar Airways is
now you know have the faith in us to do
all right that sounds very interesting
no the airport hasn't made a profit
since 2012
do you anticipate hitting break-even
shortly yeah I say we've you know the
airport was in a very bad position back
in 2013 when the Welsh government made
the decision to step in and buy it you
know for the benefit of Wales generally
and we
been on a really you know a big recovery
plan since then we're now four years
into the recovery plan that we first put
into place back in 2013 and we're fully
sort of targeting breakeven and ebb it
dollar level and indeed profit within
the next couple of year